die neue kampagne die neue große booster
kampagne von karl lauterbach karl will
klotzen und nicht mehr kleckern wie jens
spahn der immer nur gerade so auf kante
bestellt hatte eine riesen bestellung
bei der eu bei moderner und bei biontech
an neuem stoff und das soll eben auch
vorteile bringen wer gepustet ist muss
nicht mehr getestet werden wenn er in
ein lokal will in ein restaurant
sonderrechte also für gepostete tja der
ärztepräsident montgomery hat sich auch
schon dazu geäußert er findet das nicht
so gut und deshalb fragen wir jetzt mal
einen dritten professor dr klaus dieter
zastrow ist zugeschaltet facharzt für
hygiene und ehemaliger geschäftsführer
der ständigen impfkommission herr
zastrow was ist dieser meinung
erleichterungen für gepostete ist das
sinnvoll
ja natürlich absolut denn wir würden ja
sonst in der ganzen geschichte dem
impfen nicht vertrauen ich bin sogar der
meinung dass eine schon nach der zweiten
das war ursprünglich vorhergesagt und
auch von den entwicklern des impfstoffs
dass man nach zwei
impfungen bereits einen vollständigen
impfschutz hat unser dilemma ist
natürlich nach wie vor dass wir gar
nicht wissen wie viele antike einmal
rahmen muss damit man folgen in vollzeit
aber wenn man jetzt auch eine dritte
macht eine musterung die im allgemeinen
der sehr viel später kommt bei den
anderen impfung dann ist es wirklich
unsinn und jan grenzt fast an titan wenn
jetzt die grußkarten auch noch einen
test machen willst also das befeuert ist
er ich halte das auch für politisch
taktisch völlig unklug das befeuert ja
auch die impfgegner
wenn man sagt und jetzt musst du dich
trotzdem noch testen lassen dann sagt er
natürlich brüssel soll ich mich denn
noch ein drittes mal im wenn ihr dann
immer noch der meinung dass es wirkt gar
nicht also wir da also zweimal geübt das
finde ich schon ab werk außer jahres
sein okay dritte impfung auch noch aber
dann wirklich solltest nicht mehr
erfordern aber jetzt hast du es doch
trotzdem gemeinde gegenüber denjenigen
die vielleicht gerade lesen sind oder
die sich haben gerade zum ersten mal
impfen lassen die haben ja
wahrscheinlich auch noch sehr sehr viele
antikörper und die fallen hier völlig
raus dort gibt es keine erleichterung
richtig und deswegen muss man sich dafür
ihm auch was überlegen also die
jetzt tatsächlich erst ja sagen wir mal
vier fünf sechs wochen das erste mal die
in form sind okay da muss man dann
leider noch mal testen aber
bei denjenigen die
erkrankt waren und nun gelesen sind ja
also
die haben derart viel antikörper
gebildet dass da ein test völlig
überflüssig ist also eine die die beste
immunisierung ist immer die erkrankung
selbst immer egal ob die masern mumps
röteln oder sonstwas nehmen und deswegen
müssen eigentlich die gelesenen
genauso also nicht eigentlich die wissen
genau so behandelt wenn ein test ist da
völlig überfüllt die andere alternative
wäre ungeimpfte aber gesund und getestet
dass es selbst mit dem pcr test nichts
mehr wert lässt sich das medizinisch
begründen
naja
da kommen wir jetzt wieder auf die alten
sache zurück wir wissen nämlich nicht
oder andersrum der pcr test ist eben
nicht spezifisch er ist eben nicht
sowohl für die eine variante also die
die b1 variante oder nachher die delta
variante jetzt auch für die omikron wir
haben für alles immer den selben test
und deswegen ist man da vielleicht ein
bisschen skeptisch aber dennoch wir
haben immer danach gearbeitet und es
gibt auch keine neue entwicklung es gibt
auch keine neue erkenntnisse zu den test
also an sich muss dann jemand der nicht
geimpft ist und die test gemacht haben
gemacht hat der muss dann eben auch ins
geschäft rein würden aber sollte man
nicht längst nur noch auf einen einzigen
test setzen und auch hören und zwar den
antikörper test
naja die die
das funktioniert deshalb weil wir gar
nicht wissen welche
wenn welche menge von antikörpern
vorhanden sein muss um einen
vollständigen schutz haben
vielleicht war das jetzt auch so ein
bisschen unklar wir haben ja den antik
also das heißt den antigen tests und
dann haben wir den
machen wir gezählt das heißt mit dem pcr
test können wir ja viren nachweisen
wir stellen also fest der zu
untersuchende hat tatsächlich viren noch
in der mundhöhle aber was wir eben nicht
wissen und das ist der ganz
entscheidende punkt natürlich auch dabei
wir wissen überhaupt nicht sind diese
viren noch aktiv und können anstecken
oder sind es bereits virus leichen die
schon in aktiviert sind wodurch auch
immer
und gar nicht mehr ansteckungsfähigkeit
und da liegt eine wiesn fehlerquelle
drin und ich bin auch überzeugt dass
tausende von tests die positiv eingehen
ist ein positiver test aber die leute
sind gar nicht mehr ansteckungswege
sie
und sie sind auch wenn es heiße man
neuinfektionen sie sind gar nicht
erkannt sie tragen das virus zwei mund
dieser und öde aber sie sind gar nicht
erkannt sie sind symptomlos aber sollte
man nicht dahingehend mehr forschungen
betreiben also ich meinte schon den
antikörper test nicht den antigenen tel
dass man einfach irgendwann herausfinden
kann ab welchen wert die antikörper
ausreichen und wir den besonderen schutz
dann auch haben warum kriegt auch noch
da
also mit der forderung haben sie absolut
recht und das sage ich auch schon eine
ganze weile arbeit mal ernsthaft die
zeit ist so kurz wir müssten ja folgen
messbar wir müssen
tatsächlich versuchsreihen haben und ich
bin überzeugt dass da arbeiten heerschar
an um herauszukriegen
wir müssten ja leute
untersuchung auf die auf die antikörper
die sie haben und dann müssten wir sie
infizieren wir müssten sie gezielt
infizieren und sehen ob die krankheit
angeht ja also dann nehmen wir mal an
wir würden bei ihnen blut abnehmen und
sagen sie haben jetzt außen antikörper
dann sagt uns jetzt erstmal nicht weiter
ja jetzt
kontaminieren will infizieren wir sie
mit coronaviren und dann warten wir mal
ab was passiert
entweder sie wer krank oder wie wir
nicht fangen und davon müssten mal ein
paar tausend leute also zigtausend leute
so untersucht sie können sich vorstellen
mit welcher begeisterung die leute das
machen wir ja wer lässt sich schon gerne
gezielt wird mit corona viren
[Musik]
infiziert kontaminieren das wird der das
wird sehr schwierig das ist ein
erfahrungswert über jahre dann ergibt
also in der kurzen zeit jetzt wird man
das sowieso nicht hinkriegen also das
ist nicht ganz einfach es gibt jetzt so
schätzungen wo man sagt okay wenn wir
über 1000 hast dann kann nämlich
passieren hass zumindest schon mal
antikörper gebildet das ist gut wenn du
unten bei 40 50 bist von phil und
vielleicht unter 200 ala ist das eben
fraglich und und da müsste man dann
gezielt nach uns dann aber zum beispiel
wären mehr als 1000 antikörper hat ich
glaube das immer schon empfohlen der
braucht sich auch nicht noch mal impfen
zu lassen wozu denn er ist häufig durch
vielen dank für ihre erläuterungen
besten tag danke schön